this story
is about something that i went through
basically daily
in sixth grade so that would be for me
when i was 11
and this would be like 1981 to 1982
sixth grade for a lot of us is middle
school so you start out in elementary
school
and then you have middle school sixth
through eighth grade and then you have
high school
other places do it a little bit
differently in the us but that's the way
it was where i went to school and for me
it was a massive transition
because i went from going to a
public elementary school in a very rural
area the kettle moraine school district
where
you know we had like one gifted talented
person who drove all around
the entire uh school district meeting
with us like once or twice a month and
you know a lot of my classes were in
effect hey go to the library and do some
projects or there's some other
smart kids go do some things over there
and it was a transition from that that
public school where they
actually wanted to move me ahead into
seventh grade from fifth grade
to a private school and the private
school that my parents
found for me which wasn't that far from
our place
it was called university lake school and
i was able to get a scholarship there
on the basis of my test scores and who
knows what else my parents filled out
the application
and it was the kind of private school
where there were basically
two kinds of people there as far as
students go
there were students who were smart there
were students who were
rich from wealthy families and these
were
anywhere from wealthy families to like
the super rich
and you know there wasn't an awful lot
of
of mixing between the two those of you
us who were there on scholarship were
made to know that we were there on
scholarship
as a matter of fact most of the other
kids who were there on scholarship now
that i think about it who are my my
friends
they were like you know kids of
professors
at you know uw milwaukee or marquette
university and so
it was kind of a strange place there
were some really great things about it
there were some really terrible things
about it there was a lot in between
and it was very class conscious in ways
that i'll i'll tell you about in other
stories so in any case one of the things
that
we had to do at university lake school
was chores after school had finished
and these chores could be all sorts of
different things
they in effect were saving money by
making us
kids do extra work um
you know like in in seventh grade i
actually got to pair up with my friend
steve utsurith
and we had to clean all the
test tubes and beakers and stuff like
that for the chemistry lab
i don't even remember what i did for
eighth grade it must have been something
that you know i wasn't very interested
in
but in sixth grade i must have drawn the
short straw
or maybe they gave the kids who were
there on scholarship the really crappy
jobs to do
because what i was assigned was to
vacuum the library and the library
was at one end of the main
campus building there were a couple
different campus buildings as
i remember and i think they built on
additional stuff
since then there was the main building
where we had all our classes
and the cafeteria was adjoined to that
and you know you went
down this long long hallway where there
were classrooms and lockers with cubby
holes and
we only had cubby holes in middle school
the high schoolers had lockers
and you'd go all the way down to the end
and that was the
the library it was a pretty big place
and then there was another building
on campus that was there and that's
where the gymnasium was
and you know the locker rooms and the
music
and art areas and i think there were
some other things in there as well so in
any case
every day after school ended i was
supposed to support
report to the library and then get this
antiquated vacuum cleaner that was
pretty heavy
and lug it around and vacuum portions of
the library i didn't have to vacuum the
whole thing every day thank thank
goodness
but i had to vacuum quite a bit and it
would take me you know half an hour 45
minutes and then
the carpool would would pick us up
afterwards and i i remember actually the
people in the carpool
sometimes giving me dirty looks because
it would take me so long to get this job
done but it was it was one of the
crappiest jobs on campus
and i think that the justification that
they had was like oh this is character
building for these kids but i
i i'm honestly convinced that it was
just a way for them to avoid having to
pay
custodians to to do the work that we
were otherwise doing
and i kind of think it was a way to like
remind us of our
our place as well so you know what i
remember about the library there
i spent a good bit of time in it anyway
because it was it was really a great
library
it was kind of dark inside um
but it was you know it it was like
construction from the 1960s or 70s so
lots of
dark wood paneling all over the place
and you know wooden beams
and you know the stacks of books and i
love libraries already
when i was a kid growing up in that
region
it was a big treat for us to go to the
delafield public library and that was a
small library but they had things like
you know i read my
way through all the tom swift novels and
i remember reading about you know all
the different
horror movie villains like the wolf man
and i remember reading other stuff in
there
as well and then we got as a you know
treat every once in a while to go to the
waukesha library which is
much much larger than the little
delafield library and that's that's
where i picked up a lot of the science
fiction and fantasy books that i was i
was reading
when i was in you know late elementary
and then middle school
and then high school and so
getting to like go through you know i
had to vacuum right and the vacuuming
kind of sucked
but i'll talk about that in a minute but
one of the cool perks of
working in the library although not
working for the library
was getting to see all the books that
were on the stacks and so i'd go back to
them later on in the day when we'd have
like a library pass or whatever
and check them out and i remember seeing
the books that were out on display there
was one that was all about
gnomes it was kind of a big thing in the
fantasy world at the time all these
illustrations and aside you know every
once in a while you know page through it
and there were other cool things about
the library as well
you know things that were being put out
i'll mention one other thing that i'll
that i'll actually get to talking about
the
the work that was involved so i was into
wargaming when i was a kid i i don't
know exactly where i
came across it but i bought from the
aquinto
game company a game and i think it was
just called war game or something like
that
and my dad and i used to play it
together when
he would have the time and so i kind of
picked up a taste for
wargaming and then one of my neighbors
was also
into that so you know i knew about
avalon hills diplomacy i never played it
but i'd heard about it because you know
you read books about wargaming and all
that from from the library again
and you're like well that sounds like a
really cool game for those who don't
know
diplomacy is a up to seven player game
no dice there's no chance involved in it
very simple rules but very complex game
play and it was a really
you know really kind of cool game at the
time
so the high schoolers were playing it
and they would leave it out on a table
and you could see all these pieces and
you'd be like wow it looks like that
country's doing pretty well
and that country's not and so day by day
by day
as they would make moves i would get to
see who was winning and who was losing
never got to play it there as a matter
of fact i've never
actually had the chance to play it in no
i did
play it in in college in person a few
times
mostly i've played it online and so i
i was just sort of looking at it from a
distance thinking man it must be
cool to be in those classes where you
get to do uh
war gaming you know on the tabletop so
back to vacuuming right
i i would report in and then i would get
this vacuum cleaner
and it was like a heavy duty thing from
the
probably like early 70s heavy as hell
you know you had to lug it around the
cord had been duct taped a couple times
and it wasn't like the vacuum cleaner
that we had at home which wasn't like
you know state of the art but was
certainly in in better shape and i to a
little bit of back story i knew how to
vacuum
which is not a particularly hard you
know thing to do but i think some people
can't
can't really do it effectively i knew
how to vacuum because
as a kid we all had chores you know
if you had a day off you could be
guaranteed there was one or two hours
worth of chores like weeding or you know
cleaning the kitchen or
sweeping out the garage and rearranging
things and vacuuming was
one of those things that we learned to
do quite early
as kids i think by the way i think it's
really good
for kids to be brought up knowing how to
do
basic chores so when they go out as
adults they're not only not a drag on
their roommates but they they know how
to do that every
every kid should learn how to iron every
kid should learn how to cook
basic things every kid should learn how
to clean using products safely
every kid should learn how to vacuum and
so we did
you know i did a lot of vacuuming i'll
also mention too that
my uncle john he really changed
character when he started having kids
because before he and his wife my aunt
mary started having kids
he was really kind of a jerk when it
came to kids he he kind of
subscribed to the children should be
seen and not heard
view and he mellowed out once he had his
own kids and when you stayed at uncle
john's you had to earn your keep
and so the way that i would typically
earn my keep was by vacuuming and uncle
john
was a task master if you didn't vacuum
the way he wanted it vacuumed
he would let you know and you'd have to
re-vacuum the whole area
so fortunately by the time that i'm
working in the library i already know
how to vacuum
i'm you know i'm lugging this thing
around which is kind of a heavy duty
old-fashioned vacuum cleaner
and you know nobody really
checked on me all that often and the
thing that i do remember
about it that i i kind of liked it's the
same sort of thing as when you mow the
grass
you know you get those lines because
you're you're moving around like in
concentric circles the library was so
big
that you would have to vacuum sections
right and it had this super long
cord so you could actually go around
quite a bit without having to
unplug stuff and so you know you vacuum
this almost mindless activity
sort of like cutting the grass you know
you got to pay attention so you're not
bumping
anything and damaging stuff but that
that's that's what i would do
and so you know in a way it was kind of
relaxing but i also
resented having to do it because i knew
other kids had
like easier jobs and we're getting out
of there quicker
and you know it was dusty sometimes and
and it was it was heavy enough that it
kind of hurt to lug it around when you
have to like
carry it all the way up the stairs and
then back down the stairs
and i i remember that there would be
like a note
left out for me vacuum this section
vacuum this section
and so after a while became kind of
mindless monotony
you know and i'd think about other stuff
and i'd look around
you know at what was there in the
library usually there wouldn't be
anybody
else i was sort of on my own i don't
remember there being a librarian
hanging out after hours i remember
turning out the light switches and
closing up and putting the vacuum back
in its closet
after i was done now now that i'm
thinking about it
so i was like totally on my own and
i did this pretty much every day
i i did skip one day where i'd like had
enough i was kind of fed up with it
and the the person who to sign the job
to me
was my sixth grade science teacher he
later became the headmaster of
university lake school and i i don't you
know honest to god
his name was dick butt richard butt
so we all called him mr butt and he
actually went by dick
i don't i i've never understood why
somebody
would go by dick rather than richard
especially if they have such a subject
some suggestive name and i remember
being in science class and he asked me
if i'd vacuumed the day before and i was
thinking oh [ __ ] he
he he knows i didn't um but i lied
anyway and i said yeah yeah i did it
and then he said i know that you didn't
because there were some paper scraps on
the floor that didn't get vacuumed up
now you're gonna have to you know i'm
gonna have to punish you in some way i
don't remember what the punishment was
obviously they couldn't make me vacuum
anymore because i was already
doing this stupid job for them five days
a week
anyway so i think maybe i got a
detention
or something like that so i you know i
did this for
however many days there are in a school
year you know
from the beginning in august all the way
to the end
in may you know in august and
well june actually i think it was kind
of hot work because nothing was air
conditioned
um you know everything was heated of
course in the winter because this is the
the midwest um and you know
it was kind of an interesting task
looking back on it it really wasn't that
onerous of a task compared to all the
many other things that i've done and
it's just vacuuming right i've been
cleaning things
my entire life as a kid working in
restaurants
you know when i was in the army every
place that i've lived i've done my own
my own cleaning
um so it's really not that big of a deal
but i remember
you know like it kind of stuck in my
proverbial craw that i got
landed with this this task of
vacuuming up the the library and it was
a huge space for a kid i i
imagine if i were to go back on campus
it probably wasn't that big of a space
but when you're 11 years old you know
the world looks very
different to you and then like i
mentioned you know sixth grade was over
when i came back for seventh grade i got
assigned
a different job that was kind of cush
getting to clean the lab equipment i
mean you had to be a little bit careful
about you know
chemicals and your skin and stuff like
that and so we had a briefing on like
what to do if you
spill something on yourself but um
we you know we got to do a lot of easy
stuff we got to get out of there but
that was my
that was my sixth grade so in addition
to having like a full school day
which um included all these different
subjects and sometimes
art or music or gym class and
you know hanging out on this this campus
i was stuck
in that spot in the library vacuuming up
everybody else's messes i guess some
days it was worse some days it was
better
uh depending on what sort of projects
people had been doing in there
but there i'll close on this because i
want this to be you know somewhat
positive
i could look back like you know again
like cutting grass
i could look at the stuff that i'd done
for the day
and feel a sense of satisfaction it
wasn't really a sisyphean
task you know the guy rolling the
boulder up the hill only for it to have
it come down on the other side
you know because it's going to get
messed up again just like with grass
it's going to grow again
but for at least that moment you're like
ah this is nice
it's all tidy it's all clean every all
the carpet is running
in this this pattern that looks kind of
good
and so you know that was how i ended
each of my school days and then you know
i would get out and
get in the car and you know we'd be on
the
anywhere from 20 to 45 minute ride home
and get up the next day and do it again
you